notre correspondant en Ukraine Gulliver
bonjour la Russie qui vient donc de
donner une date elle va enterréner
demain l'annexion des territoires
ukrainiens
c'est une surprise en quelque sorte
puisque même si c'est du 37 septembre
est la date dont on n'avait parlé au
début quand c'est référendum ont
commencé l'information qu'on avait
c'était que ce serait effectivement le
30 septembre mais après selon des médias
avec des sources aux Kremlin ils avaient
dit que finalement ce serait plutôt
d'abord le 4 octobre et puis ce matin le
média indépendant russe a dit que ils
avaient des informations comme quoi
c'était repoussé jusqu'à novembre à
cause des problèmes avec la mobilisation
en Russie selon les journalistes de mes
12 ans et leurs sources le Kremlin
aurait décidé que c'était pas le moment
d'annoncer ces annexions alors que il y
a ces gens qui fuient la Russie ces
manifestations contre la mobilisation
etc visiblement soit c'est sur se sont
trompés soit il y a eu à nouveau un
changement d'avis et pour l'Ukraine
c'est tout de même même si c'est clair
que l'Ukraine va pas accepter ces
annexions l'Ukraine sait qu'elle est
soutenue par ses alliés dont le rejet
absolu de ces référendum c'est
soi-disant référendum et ses projets
d'annexion c'est quand même quelque
chose qui inquiète beaucoup pour
l'Ukraine puisque la Russie a clairement
dit qu'elle se réserve le droit
d'utiliser toutes sortes d'armes contre
une attaque sur son propriétaire
maintenant si elle va déclarer que ces
régions du crâne font partie de la
Russie en réalité la logique
indiquerait que cela voudrait dire que
elle peut maintenant accuser l'Ukraine
d'attaquer le territoire souverain russe
et bien sûr c'est quelque chose qui fait
un peu froid dans le dos pour les
habitants de l'Ukraine voilà pour cette
réaction à chaud alors que la Russie
vient donc un de confirmer quelle
officialiserait bien demain qu'à
l'enterrerait l'annexion donc de ces
quatre régions d'Ukraine rattachement
donc à la Russie d'ici quelques heures
climat totalement opposé dans l'Ouest du
pays où vous vous trouvez Gulliver vous
vous trouvez dans la région de de Kiev à
abucha ou après l'horreur de la guerre
peu à peu la vie est en train de
reprendre ses droits à raconter nous
oui en fait j'ai posé la question ici à
tes habitants de Bucha si la menace
nucléaire les faisait leur faisaient
peur ou si ça change leur projet de
reconstruire leur maison et de
reconstruire leur vie et la réponse a
été oui et non ces deux questions
d'abord oui on a peur mais non on va pas
arrêter d'essayer de reconstruire parce
que qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire d'autre
la reconstruction abucha et visible
partout selon une représentante de la
mairie
60 entre 60 et 70% des entreprises de la
ville aurait
renouvelé leur activité en fait derrière
moi en bas de cet immeuble où vous voyez
encore qui a des fenêtres qui manquent
et que la reconstruction est loin d'être
achevée il y a le centre pour être aux
entrepreneurs de butcha c'est un centre
un projet et gouvernemental piloté par
le ministère de la transformation
digitale
ultra moderne qui vient d'être rénovée
après avoir souffert pendant les
bombardements et qui a renouvelé son
activité en grande pompe aujourd'hui
justement pour montrer l'esprit
d'optimisme que l'Ukraine envie de
projeter qu'il y a selon les gens à qui
j'ai parlé ici à boutcha qui est réel
même si évidemment il y a beaucoup de
difficultés notamment pour le
reconstruction des immeubles parce que
il y a des gens qui ne sont pas là il y
a des gens qui n'ont pas l'argent qui
n'ont pas envie de prendre les prêts
nécessaires pour financer par exemple la
réparation des toits
merci beaucoup Gulliver crag en direct
donc de bout de chat dans la banlieue de